here's mck up ahead trying to get it to yarro kept
in and look out Patrick l with a shot that missed
the target after isinger yarro there and help from
doy give away it scores just like that K Johnson
sets up Patrick l and Columbus has struck first
it looked like the leas were going to get it out
of the line is able to keep it in here but now
you get a second chance on it it's a two-on-one
in the corner and this is one of those plays
that doy thought he could Bank it across and
get it over to the other side line a right on the
doorstep and you're right Johnson points to him
right away Johnson gets him between mccave and
he and that's a tough play for Samson off look
at he's looking back over his right already
down and when trailing in the first goal in
the National Hockey League so this has been a
team that's been able to handle the early goal
again there's peak in front deflected score
and it's a Dun nothing Columbus lead as pin
Johnson with the redirect up over samsonov and
the jackets have a two- goal lead miners after
having such a great year as a rookie last year
you win the drawback easily but this is a blind
pass that just goes to nobody and Johnson
right on the doorstep Peak does an excellent
job of this is a shot pass that's going wide
and you can see Matthews tried to get to his
Center just half second late couldn't get it and
Johnson able to tip that one in his first goal in
11 back it comes to Urich mve to the inside hands
it off proov shot hit a leg and the score Dan for
from an ankle and that one PED in like off
the back of samsonov who still can't figure
out how Columbus has made it three nothing by
sson off as he hears the Pu go behind mind is
you got a little bit of fatigue in the back
end both the defenseman have been out there
a good stretch nice job of walking in alone but
watch the reaction Samson off looks back but he
doesn't get tight to that post he's thinking
a pass so he gets his stick in position but
he doesn't get his body right up against and
that's a smart play just a backand off the
blocker and into the back of the net playan by C
Here Comes Matthews back the other way checked by
brov brov ahead and here is kov to the net
scores eard OV and it's 4 nothing [Music]
columus offense is going to come right back with
him and you talk about going downhill shikov once
he turns his body he's got the inside scope
on Brody pulls his body in and then look at
just the low shot you know so so many times
with a drive that gets past got G along the
boards Marko absorbed a hit to make the play
now warsky across seam back to G walking in
scores power play goal it's five nothing for
the visitors what a crisp passing play there
just no hesitation to get control of the puck as
you see Jones looking on hand as G but the loose
Puck battle on the boards here is one marchenko
with a backhand pass three passes later it's in
the back of the net TJ bro gets into position and
looked like he was going to have the shooting Lane
look at the adjustment by gdo pulling it inside
around the leg as he gets that one but this is
one for Samson off watch this little reaction
pulls it back around gets it past personally
I think it's the right thing it's taking him
out isn't going to help anything I think Jones
played a good game in New York get him ready for
the the game on Saturday there's luson in behind
it front scores well there's one William neander
38 seconds in and he's got his 14th of the Year
and that point strak is now seven well There He
Go something positive to grow the the fans were
getting anxious some excitement on and that
lifts your bench and you know you said here
there haven't been a lot of times where you've
been able to generate some open knes there's
a great example fenly can't get over to neand
quick enough that one just barely slide through
as neander down on one knee didn't get that up as
high as I think he wanted to but look at the zip
that he had on it chinnov away and he'll bounce
it down into the leaf Zone Riley back crashing
into him was Pall here's tamarus 1,1 points
centering it hard backand score Beauty and it's
52 you get a totally different vibe don't you
the energy is back in the building and back
on the bench it's tamarus with that open Ice
he's got two guys collapsing on him able to
keep it alive but how about the patience of
Marr and this one for M Le he thought it was
going to be going up even between the legs he's
going okay Marner is going to try to get it top
Corner instead he kind of fanned on it but it
was just perfectly executed around the Stick
of the reaching stick kind of fanned it true but
right through the five hle power play for Toronto
it was a must score and here's Timmons at the
line M fires scores must score get scor [Music]
53 second power play Jake McCain has a score
in 32 does it look like it here you know we
saw earlier him try to make that play and took
the pass away this time just put his head down
in an absolute rocket just walks into this
one look it never looks at the puck looks
exactly where he needs to put it right off
the bar down on the goal line great screen
in front by bzi KNE Lander and Riley get it
organized down low it goes to Marner right
to kick it in front KNE Lander shot rejected
another chance Matthews fired it's a one goal
game the top when you're the guy the last guy at
the top of the key and there's neander who ends
up getting this one back to him and he's thinking
pass the first time nope shot K block and look at
the last second adjustment Matthews TAPS in sck
twice he wanted it the first time time he wasn't
able to get it had to reach back and that one
hits cover off and then underneath T tap give
me the PT at that point you're just getting it
towards the net and like he's done all around
it goes to The Far Side Riley is there now tarz
moves to the front of the net back behind it's
a jam play for Matthews Tamaris gets it back in
front scor are you watching this the game is time
and 16 seconds can make watch Matthews gets the
W around does he get it play before he watchs
to but it's fittting fashion goal scorers the Pu
seems to find its way comes right back the other
side look at the little adjustment he doesn't
even know it went in he just reached back and
threw it to the net got it up in the top Corner
where's Le it's still down looking for it and
man look at those files that but shot it high
and now Matthews to the attack two on one with
barter Matthews stopped with the rebound here
it's through maybe a chance here samsonov under
the net but deadp didn't continue the wraparound
[Applause] try Linsky again dropping for Johnson
h Johnson scores it's a game winner for Ken
Johnson who set up the first goal and scores
the game winner and the Columbus Blue Jackets do
Salvage a 65 win couple of tight plays this is a
long long shift Max doy gets caught out for a
minute 26 and Johnson who really started this
thing for the Columbus Blue Jackets had a great
first period he ends up ending it but man what a
comeback third period to get us to overtime and
it's Johnson who sends the fans home buzzing